it appears that some of you are not
taking the Urgent threat of climate
change seriously enough which is why the
president of the United States wants to
remind you just how serious it really
is you know I've seen firsthand what the
reports make clear the devastating toll
of climate change and its existential
threat to all of us and is the ultimate
threat to humanity climate
change the ultimate threat I'm not sure
if President Biden really believes this
I'm not sure if Biden really believes
anything but plenty of people really do
believe this because we live in an
increasingly Pagan Age and what pagans
fear and worship ultimately is nature
that is why the old pagans the old timey
pagans would sacrifice goats and babies
and things to make it rain they
considered the ultimate threat to
mankind to be material chiefly climate
change that was true for all of history
until the Advent and spread of
Christianity which crucially considers
the ultimate threat to humanity to be
immaterial chiefly sin so we stopped
living in survi fear of the weather gods
for about 1700
years and now we're at it again here
comes the new boss same as the old boss
I'm Michael nlls this is the Michael
nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Nikki Haley is
in hot water for a proposal that she had
on social media reform that a lot of
conservatives are saying is very lib uh
we will get to that in a moment because
it's actually pretty interesting
proposal ultimately probably not the
greatest idea but we'll get to it in
just a moment first though on this point
of religious confusion Rafael waro who
is a socialist senator from Georgia who
fancies himself a pastor of some sort or
other uh he just attacked Evangelical
Protestants for supporting Donald Trump
here is his argument or lack
thereof does it bother you that the
Evangelical Community seems to be
continue to very much be behind on Donal
Trump is that surprising it's a deep
contradiction
mhm it's a deep contradiction and um I
think that um when the history of this
period is
written
um we we will have a lot to say about
about that um you cannot account for
some of the divisive forces that work in
our country MH sad L without reference
to what's happening in huge seg segments
of the American Church um I come out of
a tradition that has always tried to use
our faith to bring us together um I like
the way Jimmy Carter used his faith I
like the way Martin Luther King Jr and
uh Ella Baker and and uh white brothers
and sisters like James ree um in the
midst of this Civil Rights Movement how
they use their faith
there's actually a lot there even though
waro begins and it sounds like he's got
nothing he says you know it's really bad
these evangelicals supporting Trump you
know it's really bad and someday people
are going to explain why it's bad I'm
not going to explain it now because I
don't know because I can't say anything
about it because I don't have an
argument but someday trust me someday
later later on people are going to talk
about why it's so bad that these
evangelicals keep supporting Trump
instead of socialists like me but then
he almost hints at an argument he he
shows his cards on his error with regard
to Christianity and his error it boils
down to that one word
use he said you know man I like how all
these other left-wing people used their
faith used their faith what is faith
faith is the substance of things hoped
for and the evidence of things unseen
Faith now has become a substitute word
for religion and what is religion
religion is a a habit of virtue that
inclines the will to give God what he
deserves it's not something you use it's
not something in service of another
thing it's giving to God what he
deserves that's what it is Faith is a
theological
virtue and religion is giving to God
what he deserves but for the libs it's
just another thing to be used
used in service of what well Rafael waro
makes it clear religion is just
something to be used in service of
political change change on this Earth
social engineering which is really
ironic because that's what the libs
always accuse the conservative
Christians of doing they say you just
use your religion in service of your
right-wing ends but I don't think that's
fair at all I don't think that's true
and in fact I think like so many other
leftwing attacks on conservatives it's
just projection and here you have
Raphael waro admitting it himself he
says yeah I just I I just want to use my
faith in service of politics here let me
tell you about my great faith Idols my
the people that I
admire in this case idolatry probably
being used precisely but these are the
these are the people that I look up to
when it comes to religion and he names
some names that I've never heard of he
says Martin Luther King and Martin
Luther King had many admirable qualities
but Martin Luther
King denied really Central aspects of
the Christian faith he he denied the
Divinity of Christ he denied the
Miracles okay he denied he he denied
really essential aspects of Christianity
so you might say he was a great social
reformer you might say he was a great
political activist a political leader
but he was far from an Orthodox
Christian but for waro that's fine it
doesn't matter what you believe it
doesn't it doesn't
matter
ultimately what your faith consists of
and where your hope ultimately lies
because all religion is is just a way to
affect
politics that's what it's about we just
got to use it and and for for warno even
further you this is so telling he says
the reason that these evangelicals who
support Trump are bad is because they're
divisive they want to just divide people
and I like people like Jimmy Carter who
use their religion to bring people
together what does our Lord tell us if
you if you've read the gospels if you've
been to church more than a few times you
might have heard that Christ says I come
not to bring peace but a
sword I
come ultimately yes to unite people with
me and my father who are one in heaven
but not to just have everybody Kumbaya
on Earth our our Lord did not come to
build the Tower of
Babel so no I I I will divide children
from their parents okay I will I I bring
a sword I bring division in a worldly
sense and I bring that unity in a
Heavenly sense in an ultimate sense and
for Libs like rapael waro it's
completely the opposite for Libs like
rapael waro it's all just about holding
hands and building the Tower of Babel
here on Earth because we're not looking
at ultimate ends we're not looking it's
just like what Joe Biden's talking about
with the the ultimate threat to humanity
being the weather no the ultimate threat
to humanity Christianity tells us is not
anything here on Earth it's not a bullet
it's not the weather it's not a disease
the ultimate threat is your soul who
cares if you can win the whole world but
you lose your soul the soul is going to
persist a lot longer when we talk about
the soul we talk about eternity when we
talk about just fleshy things that will
pass away
ultimately it is Rafael War has no idea
that he's conveying all of these things
but but it's a it's a pregnant answer to
the question from Jen Zaki and it's a
it's a reminder that the ultimately the
leftist religion is
worldliness now I mentioned ultimately
you don't need to fear bullets but you
know on Earth if you want to preserve
your body and live a little while longer
it's probably a good idea to be cautious
of them which is why you ought to check
out bulletproof everyone right now I got
a bulletproof everyone.com use code
nolles bulletproof everyone is
revolutionizing everyday safety with
their exclusive line of bulletproof
clothing imagine your favorite jacket
your favorite hoodie with at added
bulletproof protection that is what
bulletproof everyone offers everyday
clothing with an extraordinary twist
these clothes are designed to look and
feel just like your usual wardrobe items
but with a hidden layer of safety the
ultimate blend of fashion and function
you can say goodbye to the bulkiness of
regular soft armor it is so lightweight
and comfortable you will forget that you
are wearing anything at all despite how
thin and light they are these clothes
provide a robust defense against various
threats with their 3A option capable of
stopping up to a 44 Magnum that is their
top tier protection in a Sleek package
best part they're as easy to care for as
your regular clothes wear wash repeat no
special handling required they even
offer free tailoring with every single
order bulletproof everyone sent us a
custom jacket and check this
out this is not only one of the
backpacks that they sent me this is the
same backpack that you will get for free
with any purchase of clothing I travel a
lot so it's nice to have peace of mind
that I'm always protected stay protected
without sacrif iing style or Comfort
bulletproof everyone is not just
changing clothing they're changing the
game in personal safety right now our
listeners can get 10% off plus a free
bulletproof backpack with the purchase
of any bulletproof clothing just use
code nolles to check out at bulletproof
everyone.com bulletproof everyone.com
promo code nolles speaking of secular
liberal culture really sad story I meant
to get to it a couple days ago you know
about the little British girl Indie
Gregory she was a baby who had a disease
and uh the UK government said we don't
want to pay for her medical treatment
anymore so going to kill her and I had
her father Dean Gregory come on the show
who was making a last minute appeal to
the courts sadly the courts shot it down
the Italian government gave Indie
Gregory citizenship so the UK government
ultimately ended up killing an Italian
citizen which creates an international
legal crisis that will probably just be
brushed aside but it it seems
significant to me uh the Vatican offered
to treat baby Indie Gregory at the
Bambino Jesu hospital but the UK was so
embarrassed by this the UK couldn't
allow the baby to go seek treatment
elsewhere because that would be an
indictment on the UK it would be it
would be a global embarrassment that
some other government has to step in to
save a British citizen because the
British government just wants to kill
that citizen to save a few bucks even a
little innocent baby like Indie
Gregory now we knew this was the way the
story was almost certain to end from the
very beginning and that is what happened
but there there was one happy little
turn before the story before Indie
Gregory's Earthly story ended which is
that Mr Gregory the father had the baby
baptized and it's not as though Dean
Gregory was some devout practicing
Christian he has not been that in fact
that's what makes the story even more
powerful Dean Gregory says I'm not a
religious guy but but he says quote when
I was in court I felt as if hell pulled
at me
I thought that if hell exists then
Heaven Must exist too I thought that if
the devil exists then God must exist too
I have seen what hell is like and I want
Indie to go to
heaven show me the flaw with that
argument that's a beautiful beautiful
argument that's
great some
people won't like this argument because
they'll say well you know no that's
you're you're not making a perfectly
rational argument for the existence of
God and for the historicity of the
gospels and for the this and it's not
neat and Pat and to no this is a great
this is a great ARG this is a much much
realer argument frankly because he's
saying you know yeah I'm not religious
at all and I I I can't recite to you
Thomas aquinus is five ways for knowing
the existence of God but I tell you what
when I was in that British courtroom and
that that evil judge was killing my
daughter I knew what evil was I knew
that evil exists I knew that evil has a
personality I could feel a rather
serious simulacrum of hell
and with all the devil's minations in
that courtroom he undid himself with all
the devil's minations he undermined
himself because it occurred to me that
if the devil exists and if hell
exists well then God in heaven must
exist too and God in Heaven Must Be much
greater than the devil in hell and so he
had his baby
baptized I to this I don't know what he
currently thinks about all these things
but he knew enough to say I am going to
do what I can to save my daughter even
the fact that he had to confront
something that most of us can push off
which is the fact of
mortality we're all going to end up in
the same place as Indie Gregory most of
us don't end up there at eight months
old but but we're all going to end up
there at some point and so it you know
the silver lining in that storm cloud
which is which is a storm cloud that
we're all going to face which is the
fact of a fallen world and our
immortality he was able to find that
silver lining there which is the
confrontation of death it's it's why uh
why Dr Johnson had a famous line which
is depend upon its s when a man knows
he's to be hanged in in a fortnite it
concentrates the Mind
wonderfully say when we when we actually
have to face the thing that we put off
as best we can for our entire lives
namely the fact of our death our
inevitable death it concentrates us and
it it doesn't confuse us what the
atheist and the Liberals want us to
believe is well it just has us
desperately grasping its straws and
wishcasting this notion that we can live
forever but it's really the opposite it
it has us focus and say okay well what
is the meaning of my life what am I am I
just a bag of chemicals or am I
something more than that do my natural
desires and longings for something
Beyond this world point to something
that does exist Beyond this world do
does my natural intuition and deduction
of the metaphysical the fact that we
know we know for certain there are
things that are not merely physic in
this world like I don't know mathematics
the fact that there are metaphysical
things does that imply something more
about metaphysical reality and all of
that hit Mr Gregory like a ton of bricks
in that courtroom and the the the
personification of evil that he saw
occurring around him and to him and
therefore the personification of good
ultimately ultimately a happy ending
albeit with much pain in the meantime
now speaking of this speaking of
politically motivated conversions I
teased a story a few days ago that I I
do want to get to at least briefly Ian
hery Ali very prominent political figure
she was raised
Muslim she recoiled against that she
became an atheist and a big anti-islam
and islamism campaigner and she was a a
very popular figure in the west and
remains a popular figure in the
west she's converted to
Christianity and she's done it in a way
that some Christians don't like she has
converted
politically she has converted sort of
the way that Indie
Gregory was converted through her Father
which is politically as a result of
political
events though though for ION hery Ali
it's even it's even more political in
that she says the reason that I'm a
Christian is be a civilization cannot
withstand barbarism without Christianity
so she is she is describing Christianity
in a kind of instrumental way she says
why do I call myself Christian now part
of the answer is global Western
Civilization is under threat from three
different related forces the Resurgence
of great power authoritarianism and
expansionism in the forms of the Chinese
Communist party and Putin's Russia the
rise of global islamism political Islam
which threatens to mobilize a vast
population against the west and the
viral spread of woke ideology which is
eating into the moral fiber of the Next
Generation she says we Endeavor to fend
off these threats in with modern secular
tools military economic diplomatic and
technological efforts to defeat bribe
persuade appease or surveil and yet with
every round of conflict we find
ourselves losing ground we're either
running out of money with our national
debt in the tens of trillions or we're
losing our lead in the tech race with
China we can't fight off these
formidable forces unless we can answer
the question what is it that unites us
the response that God is dead which n
gives is insufficient so too does the
attempt to find Solus in the rules-based
international liberal order which is
just a bunch of gobble words that have
not uh done very much for us recently
the only credible answer says aan her
Ali lies in our desire to uphold the
legacy of the judeo-christian tradition
that is why I no longer consider myself
a Muslim apostate but a lapsed atheist
of course I still have a great deal to
learn about Christianity I discover a
little more at church e Sunday but I
have recognized in my own long journey
through a wildness Wilderness rather of
fear and self-doubt that there is a
better way to manage the challenges of
existence and either Islam or unbelief
had to offer and and so there are going
to be Christians who criticize Ali and
say well you you shouldn't in the same
way that I just criticized rapael waro
you shouldn't just use Christianity as
some instrument toward a political
end but whereas for rapael waro that
appears to be the the end of his faith
Journey while for rapael waro this is
something that he has considered for
decades working as a professional
Christian he says no this is what
Christianity is about actually recoiling
against people whose Faith points to
something higher than politics for I on
hery Ali this is only the beginning and
she is admitting this here in the column
she's saying I have a lot to learn I'm
learning a little bit more every time I
go to church every time I read something
and so I'm learning but what what she's
saying is the political is what pulled
me into
Christianity not that I am a Christian
instrumentally so that I can
achieve certain political ends she's
saying the political problem is what
first turned me on to the fact that that
all of these other Solutions don't work
and maybe that's that's why Christianity
has something to recommend it maybe
Christianity even possibly is true
that's fine by me we live in a very
modern liberal individualist age and
modern
certainly a number of strains of modern
protestantism not all but but a number
of them are highly
individualistic and highly emotivist and
they'll say well you just need to be
feeling certain things individually
forget about the church forget about the
community forget about the reality of
sacraments just you got to just feel
stuff man going on inside of you and if
you don't feel it your faith is not real
that is not historically what Christians
have believed in fact there have been
whole communities and whole Nations that
have converted on
mass the political has often LED convert
to the faith for goodness sakes Armenia
is the oldest Christian country in the
world the country converted in what was
it 301 or 310 it was before the Edict of
Milan legalized Christian relaxed the
the prohibitions on Christianity
throughout the Roman
Empire that was a that was a conversion
a number of the tribes that took over
the Roman Empire after the fall of the
Empire converted on mass Nations used to
be called Christian nations our
civilization used to be a Christian
civilization the political order does
not necessarily have to be totally
opposed to Christianity there does not
necessarily have to be a firm separation
of church and state in fact there never
has been for all of history anywhere in
the world not in this country not in any
other country the question is merely
what religion is animating your country
and your civilization right now in in
modern liberal culture we've returned to
worshiping the nature Gods just as they
did before the Advent of Christianity
and we say the the ultimate threat is
that it won't rain this season so we
have to make a few more sacrifices and
do a little more of a rain dance put on
our our big rituals where we go March
around and dance and listen to a a
Swedish child yell at us and if we do
that for long enough then the nature
Gods will will smile and and show their
favor to us and we'll get rain for the
Harvest that's the that's the new
religious ritual that animates our
civilization it's a ridiculous one it's
not going to be conducive to to
flourishing personally or politically or
we could go back to the one that served
us very well for at least 1,700 years
that's the one that ion her allei is is
realizing might serve us well again now
when you want to serve your dog and
improve your dog's health you got to
check out Ruff greens right now go to
Ruff greens.com the holidays are coming
up fast while you're out shopping for
your kids family and friends don't
forget to shop for your pets too give
your dog the gift of a healthier and
happier life with Ru greens naturopathic
doct Dennis black the founder of rough
greens is focused on improving the
health of every dog in America dog food
might as well be considered dead food
since it doesn't have a lot of nutrition
to it nutrition is not brown it's green
let rough greens sorry rough greens
bring your dog's food back to life rough
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't even need to go out and get new
dog food just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every single time right
now you can get a free jump start trial
bag right now your order jumpstart trial
bag delivered straight to your door in
just a few business days go to Ruff
greens.com slm or call 844 ruff1 123
that is Ruff greens.com slm or call 844
rough rfff one 123
today speaking of civilization breaking
down Secret Service agents just had to
fire on a criminal while they were
protecting Naomi Biden Naomi Biden is
one of Joe Biden's
grandkids Secret Service is protecting
Naomi Biden I believe she was living at
the white house for a while she's an
adult I mean she's not like a 5-year-old
but she was she was being driven around
this is in Washington DC and they're out
somewhere in
Georgetown Secret Service notices that a
bunch of thugs are trying to bust into a
secret service car and they were so
aggressive about it that the Secret
Service actually had to end up opening
fire on them and this is the crazy part
the Secret Service didn't hit the guys
and they have still haven't caught them
at least according to news
reports this this is a family member of
the sitting president of the United
States out in Georgetown which is
supposed to be the nicest neighborhood
of Washington DC it's supposed to be
basically inaccessible by public
transportation because they wanted to
keep the Riff Raff out looks like the
Riff ra got in there and they're trying
to carjack the Secret Service and the
secret so much so that the Secret
Service have to shoot at them and the
Secret Service can't even hit them and
they get away what is happening to our
country what is happening to our civil
order and some people are going to hear
this story and say no there must be more
to the story than that something doesn't
seem right I know for a fact this
happened the way I know for a fact this
happened merely through the criminality
of our political order merely merely
through the the breakdown of Law and
Order that happened specifically in
Washington DC is one time I was in
Washington not that long ago a few years
ago and I was out with a politician
prominent politician and we were we were
out a little bit late and he goes to his
car and and he comes back in he says
someone broke into my
car this this was not a targeted hit
this was not someone trying to get State
Secrets or anything like that it was
just a smashing grab and so so we wait
around for the cops call the DC Metro
cops DC Metro Cops show up they say hey
sorry this is
a this is a common occurrence here he
say hold on you're telling me that a
sitting prominent
politician is can get his bag stolen out
of a car in in a nice part of DC we were
not far from the White
House and it wasn't that it was late I
guess it wasn't like that
late and the cops say yeah there's
nothing we can do this happens so
frequently in even the nice
neighborhoods maybe especially in the
nice
neighborhoods so so an ordinary citizen
doesn't stand a chance if it's going to
happen to sitting politicians to the
granddaughter of the president of the
United States in the nicest parts of
town it's happening to so many people
and and it gets back to an element of
our government that is that is really
lacking right now which is yes there are
ideological fights yes we differ over
certain issues and we can get down to
the fundamental philosophical
differences and all of them but
shouldn't we all be able to agree that
smash grabs are bad shouldn't we isn't
there a level of competence that that
ought to be required of our politicians
to say no go arrest the burglars go
arrest the
carjackers isn't there and and we paper
over that incompetence with ideological
distinctions where you have someone like
Rashida Talib who says we need to
abolish all prisons and let all the
criminals off the hook and it's
society's fault or whatever but I think
there's just a there's just a basic
incompetence here you know be being
mayor being a a prosecutor being a chief
of police it's a job and some people are
good at their jobs and some people are
bad at their jobs they their basic
requirements of the job and our
politicians not only fall into all sorts
of ideological confusion they also just
can't do their jobs and when you have a
breakdown in competence your your civil
order is going to break down really
really quickly speaking
of speaking of politicians Nikki Haley
is in hot water right now because
she has suggested a new form of social
media
reform uh that would get rid of the
anonymous accounts online take it
away when I get into office the first
thing we have to do social media
accounts social media companies they
have to show America their algorithms
let us see why they're pushing what
they're pushing the second thing is
every person on social media should be
verified by their name that's first of
all it's a national security threat when
you do that all of a sudden people have
to stand by what they say and it gets
rid of the Russian Bots the Iranian Bots
and the Chinese Bots and then you're
going to get some civility when people
know their name is next to what they say
accountability and they know their
pastor and their family members going to
see it it's going to help our kids and
it's going to help our country so the
first part is a good idea the first part
about making the tech companies show the
algorithm so that we can make sure that
they're not suppressing conservatives or
uh Shadow Banning conservatives I think
that's a great idea but that that great
idea is why the second idea is so
confusing because if you're
acknowledging that tech companies are
pulling all sorts of shenanigans
especially against
conservatives then why would you want
to De anonymize those very same
persecuted
conservatives I understand the argument
in the abstract every everyone's piling
on Nikki right now and saying it's a
terrible idea to force people to stand
by their words in principle I don't
think that's a terrible idea I think
that's actually a very good idea to hold
people to certain standards and make
them stand by their
words if the government were not
persecuting normal people for being
normal that's the problem that's the key
here the fact that we're acknowledging
that the government and the private
corporations doing the bidding of the
government but without the
accountability often at the direct
behest of the government as we saw
uncovered in all those files from
Facebook and Twitter where the FBI and
other government organizations are going
in to the big tech companies and saying
hey ban that guy hey suppress that
account hey shut that conservative up so
if we know that if we know that people
are being persecuted by the government
not for committing crimes not for being
extremists but for being normal
then but by De anonymizing the people
you're you're just making them sitting
ducks for a predatory politic
order there is a longstanding history of
anonymous political discourse in America
it goes all the way back to the
Federalist Papers puus was the the
pseudonym of Alexander Hamilton James
Madison and John Jay writing the
Federalist defending the
Constitution should we have de
anonymized them probably not a good
idea
so it's a problem with the haly campaign
because I think she some of the
criticism of her is undeserved here
there there would be something good
about making people stand up for what
they believe in and holding people
accountable for their
words if if it were 20 years
ago if if the government were not going
into Catholic churches and spying on the
supposedly dangerous extremist
traditionalist Catholics going to mass
if the government were not arresting
pro-life activists just for standing and
peacefully protesting outside abortion
clinics infanticide Mills if if the doj
were not comparing parents who don't
want their kids to be taught weird sex
stuff in school to
terrorists if we weren't living in that
world yeah okay we don't we don't need
Anonymous accounts but in that world we
certainly
do in that world this the look some of
the greatest accounts on all of social
media are pseudonymous accounts I I
retweet many of them frequently speaking
of presidential
candidates then there were five what
right now we still have roughly I guess
there are some who don't make the
debates but are still technically
running but right now we have six
presidential candidates we've got Dan
santis Christie Nikki Haley Tim Scott
the
ramaswami and Trump who is polling out
polling all of them by like 45
points but for the ones who show up to
the debate there's the five of them well
now Another One Bites the Dust Tim
Scott's got a big announcement to
make one of the things I would recommend
to every single American I know it's not
possible by the way if you ever want to
love your country more run for president
traveling this country meeting people
has been one of the most fantastic
experiences of my entire life I love
America more today than I did on May
22nd but when I go back to Iowa it will
will not be as a presidential uh
candidate I am suspending my campaign I
think the voters uh who are the most
remarkable people on the planet have
been really clear that they're telling
me not now Tim I don't think they're
saying Trey no but I do think they're
saying not now and so I'm going to
respect the voters and I'm going to hold
on and keep working really hard and uh
look forward to another
opportunity this is really mature it's
funny as Trey gy there former
Congressman Trey gy who's now in Fox
News he tries to push Scott and he says
no come on what are you talking about
you're from South Carolina we're coming
up on the South Carolina race you're
crazy why would you drop out now and Tim
Scott says yeah because I'm not going to
win Tim Scott I don't think this is some
mellian kind of maneuver where he's
making back room deals even or
calculations maybe he cut a deal with
the Trump campaign but I don't know that
he did that I think he's a pretty normal
guy Tim Scott and I think he's just
looking at the numbers he's saying oh
yeah I'm not I'm not going anywhere this
race people seem to like me I I'm not
like Chris Christie it's not that people
hate me and never want me to run for
president again they like me they just
it's not going to be me it's going to be
Trump and then if something crazy
happens and his 45-point lead goes away
it's going to be either DeSantis or
Haley but it's just not going to be me
and so I'm not going to waste the voters
time I'm not going to waste their money
I'm not going to degrade Myself by
sticking in this race for no reason and
I'm going to live to fight another day
I'm a young man and it's okay I'm going
to keep fighting Tim Scott ran a smart
runner-up campaign in that he
didn't he didn't destroy his future
political
prospects in a way that DeSantis by
going up against Donald Trump so
directly may have seriously hampered his
future political prospects Nikki Haley
by supporting Trump and then opposing
Trump and then supporting Trump again
saying I'm not going to for president
Trump runs and then running against
Trump she's she's probably hurt her
future political prospects I'm not
saying it's totally dead for either of
them but if they lose this race I don't
know that they're going to come out
better for it Tim Scott I think probably
will it's very very normal very much the
right thing to do and so now Chris
Christie is just salivating he's saying
oh finally here we go baby the fact that
Chris Christie is down to the final five
is so outrageous there were sitting
Governors fairly popular senators in
there and somehow Chris
Christie listen Maybe the Chris ass
sance is not totally dead H now speaking
of Mr Trump you know the number one guy
in the Republican race
Democrats they're I think they're
beginning to realize he is probably the
nominee so they've got to train their
sights on him they've got they've got to
pull out the big guns now okay they
they've got a new strategy well no
they've got it no it's the same strategy
they were doing yesterday it's the same
strategy they've been doing for seven or
eight years Adam Schiff saying that
Trump is like Hitler I also want to ask
you about some of Donald Trump's
increasingly authoritarian rhetoric
because it's just so important to keep
talking about this I mean he is echoing
language used by Hitler um and musolini
his campaign seems to be doubling down
on that to even contemplate uh electing
someone who will cling to power the way
Donald Trump tried who Embraces the
language of dictators tries to
dehumanize the opposition calling them
Vermin just like Hitler and musolini um
you know when someone like that tells
you what they're going to do and he's
telling us he's going to weaponize the
justice department and won't leave power
again and not without even more of a
fight you need to listen to them and you
certainly can't put them anywhere near
the levers of power again you need to
listen to them cuz he's Hitler cuz he's
Hitler did did you hear me he's super
Hitler why didn't this work in 2016 I
said let me I'll try to say he is Hitler
Hitler yeah we heard you buddy we heard
you Trump is Hitler and Bush was
Hitler and the other Bush I don't know
if they called the other Bush Hitler he
was so nice you know but he didn't pose
a real threat to them and he lost his
re-election bid but Reagan was certainly
Hitler and bar Goldwater was Hitler and
Nixon was Hitler and they're all they're
all Hitler okay
no but darn guys it's not working I said
musolini no melini is less scary than
Hitler okay uh well if we elect him he
won't leave power if he
loses yeah but he he will though because
he did he did last time even though you
guys rigged the election and like a lot
of people knew it and it was pretty
obvious because the pipes were bursting
and changed all the election laws
illegally in some cases and to benefit
you and even even then he did leave
power on time he didn't even have a late
checkout
so yeah so he's not he's not going to
ship anyone off on the box cars he's not
going to invade Czechoslovakia he's not
going to cling to power and and refuse
to leave we know all of that even if
you're stupid
fear-mongering we're
plausible we know he won't do that
because and this is I think the real
Advantage Trump has in
this weird sort of re-election campaign
he was already president and we saw what
happened when he was President we saw
how he left office we saw how terrible
the country got after he was President
because Joe Biden ruined all the good
stuff he had done I think these
arguments by the
Democrats sometimes work I just don't
think they work after the guy served a
term left office and decided to run
again that's I think a little window
into the Democrat strategy and when you
are thinking about the windows into your
house
you've got to check out Renewal by
Anderson right now text nolles to 200
300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before for many others it is not
something they want to do it's something
they have to do have you put off
replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive well I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free quote
from Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible supported
by the best people in the industry in
fact I know this cuz one of my cousins
works for Renewal by Anderson and has
actually for years before they came on
the show as an Advertiser I then got an
email from a carpenter totally
unsolicited who said Michael I heard you
talk about Renewal by Anderson they are
absolutely the greatest when I work on a
home I can tell right away when Renewal
by Anderson has done the windows because
they are top quality they they're
offering a free inhome or virtual
consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payment zero
interest for a year teex nolles to 200
300 for your free consultation save 375
bucks off every window 750 bucks off
every door these savings will not last
long be sure to check it out text NOS to
200 300 that is nolles to 200 300
texting privacy policy in terms of
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting rules for recurring automated
text marketing messages message and data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to windowappointment now.com for full
offer details Black Friday is coming and
the daily wire has the best deals around
starting Monday get 50% % off a
dailywire plus membership and all kinds
of amazing deals on Jeremy's razor
products and tons of merch from our
dailywire shop there is something for
everyone go to dailywire.com blackf
Friday and get the full guide to all of
our Black Friday deals do not forget to
tune in all next week find out more
remember these deals start on Monday run
through Cyber Monday but we will sell
out fast do not wait get the guide and
start checking off your holiday shopping
list one more time dailywire.com blackf
Friday for the best deals of the year my
favorite comment yesterday is from
Dominic zelenak who says impressive very
nice now let's see Paul Allen San
Francisco says Gavin Nome yes that's so
true so true Governor baitman we'll get
to that Governor baitman has turned San
Francisco into Beijing which was an
improvement over it was what it was
before before it was like some gutter
you know in in the back alleys of
Honduras or something and so it's gotten
a little bit better now now it's just a
replica of Beijing we we will get to
that probably tomorrow first though on
this point of the hollow attacks on
Trump why I think Trump is actually
stronger in 2024 than he was in 2020 is
because it's for it's for one of the
reasons that some people consider Trump
weaker but I think it's actually an
advantage for a a wild eccentric
candidate like Trump which is in a way
he's kind of yesterday's news here is
typical liberal interview liberal
interviewer Hollywood star being
interviewed barest risean saying if
Trump is elected she can't live in the
country you've known of you've known and
supported a lot of political figures
with friends with the clintons I'm not
going to get into you dating Pierre
Trudeau but you have politicians in more
than one country shall we say what do
you make of the political climate of the
United
States bad well I like Biden mhm I like
Biden I think he's done a good job I
think he's compassionate he's smart he
reports the right things how do you feel
about the Spectre of a second Trump
Administration I will
move I can't live in this country if
that's if he became president but where
would you go where would you go if
probably to England MH I like
England England is very nice but she's
serious she's not telling a joke here I
would move I would move if Trump became
president I couldn't live in this
country
if Trump became
president except you did well that's
true I
did yeah you lived here for four years
when Trump was yeah that's true I did I
I did and it was fine right you're
totally fine you're okay you're alive
you're you th you probably made even
more money than you previously had and
everything was fine well yeah but I
couldn't do it
again this is why I think the the
reelect especially with this
intermediate period uh where Biden has
been president president where
everything's gone to pot I think it puts
Trump in a stronger position because it
it
defangs the the attacks what are the
attacks on Trump that work
now he's Hitler and he's going to kill
everyone well he didn't do that he is
going to start World War II actually no
Biden's starting World War III Don
Donald Trump was the best foreign policy
president in my lifetime it was the most
most peaceful president I I've ever seen
in my whole life uh well well okay Trump
fine when he's president but he won't
leave office yeah he did though and he
didn't want to and you rigged the
election but he left
anyway well we just it will the country
will be unlivable for the liberal Elites
the liberal Elites were fine you all
threatened to leave and then he got
elected and you stayed and you were fine
and now you're just doing this it's just
so exhausting it's so silly because it's
just the same you're like robots you
know it's the same nonsense over and
over
again but it this time you look even
more ridiculous because you're you've
either proven yourselves to be
Hypocrites and proven yourselves to be
unserious or you've proven your warnings
to be specious and
ridiculous which is why by the way
you're now
seeing the field winnow in the race and
you're seeing the endorsements begin to
coales around Trump whether you like
Trump whether you hate Trump there's a
reason why in Florida a number of people
who had previously endorsed to s are now
endorsing Trump certain people are are
who had been on the fence are still
endorsing people like Dan santis
potentially like Haley I'm thinking of
Kim Reynolds that was a big one in Iowa
the the governor of Iowa but generally
the movement seems to be for
endorsements into the Trump Camp because
even if the people endorsing Trump right
now don't even like Trump that much even
if they had previously endorsed Ronda
santis and they ran they ran against
Trump they realize that it just looks
like the guy is going to be the nominee
and they're going to get on the winning
team this is including the new Speaker
of the House Mike Johnson as far as I
know you have not endorsed the former
president yet uh for 2024 and this is
everybody's watching this show right now
this if you're going to do that this
would be a great great time to do it Mr
Speaker you ready I I have done it yeah
I I have I have endorsed him
wholeheartedly um look I was uh one of
the closest allies that President Trump
had in Congress he had a phenomenal
first term those first two years as you
all know we brought about the greatest
economic numbers in the history of the
world not just the country because his
policies worked and I'm I'm all in for
president Trump I had no I expect he'll
be our nominate yeah and he's going to
win it and we have to make Biden a
one-term president we have to do that
now I don't mean to insinuate here that
Mike Johnson is only endorsing Trump
because the writing is on the wall I
don't think that's the case I think he
was a trump supporter before and I I
there's no reason to believe he's not
totally sincere and Earnest
here but that's a big endorsement he
didn't have to endorse this
early speaker of the house is a big
endorsement and there are a lot of other
people who are endorsing I think in a
less sincere way but simply because they
see that the writing is on the wall and
in part this is because Trump made a bet
the BET was I think the nominations
locked up I'm not even going to show up
to the debates that could have backfired
on him and the voters could have said
hey
man you you're disrespecting us we want
you to come make your case you need to
earn our vote that's what Haley and
DeSantis and the other Republicans
argued and it just doesn't seem to have
worked so with the writing on the wall
you can expect more endorsements and you
can expect a more concerted strategy
from the Democrats to call Trump Hitler
even more loudly and with even more of a
serious face on it and you can expect
more celebrities to threaten to leave
the country and you can expect more uh
liberals to sacrifice their children and
their property to Nature gods and you
you can just expect more of the same
that we've seen for years and frankly
even millennia the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code noes canw a
check out for two months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans